this is part of our year-long public
workshop series and we're so excited to
have a base here with us this evening
and she's a fellow at our Summer
Institute in 2008 and this is her first
time back in Colombia since then and I
think she'll say a little bit about how
that experience shaped the trajectory of
this project sort of bent it in a new
direction Mary and before formally
introduced her she's an independent
scholar and interdisciplinary artist to
utilize the oral history and
ethnographic methodologies to explore in
an individual and cultural identity
she's the author of decades her god an
oral history of cloistered nuns which
just came out in 2013 with Oxford and
she's working on a collaborative
documentary that she's going to show us
some in-process clips from tonight
called chosen suspension of disbelief in
the Jesus cage she received an MFA in
Visual Arts from the University of
Chicago where she studied visual
anthropology and her multimedia exhibit
erased from the landscape the hidden
lives of clustered nuns has been shown
in galleries and museums and she's
presented her work at academic
conferences and nationally and so we
have a great opportunity tonight to hear
about a project students sort of long
and untwisted paths and different media
and different disciplinary frameworks
and and I'm so glad that you all here I
want to mention that this talk is
co-sponsored by insight and it's part of
the paul f ladder it's about lecture
series and the Philby books for sale in
the hallway outside after every stone
so welcome thank you thank you very much
this is really exciting for me because I
told Amy beforehand this is kind of
jumping into the story a little bit but
Columbia and attending the Summer
Institute a couple of years ago in 2008
was really instrumental that experience
is really instrumental in the formation
of this project not only in over the
over several years a shifting of my
methodological approach but in coming to
understand that this wasn't such a
common topic in oral history and to
really pursue it it really picked up the
pace after I attended the Summer
Institute here so for the past eight
years now since 2005 I've been working
with a community of cloistered monastic
oyster contemplative nuns they adhere to
the Poor Clare colleting Porter it's a
Franciscan Order so st. Claire followed
st. Francis to a sissy and then that was
in 1212 the order was the rule was
approved and then this order was
reformed by Saint Colette
so it's Poor Clare ecology this is one
of the strictest religious orders in
existence they make vows of poverty
chastity obedience and enclosure the
enclosure entails a metal grill
and here's a still from some video
footage this is in the trailer I think
this is the downstairs parlor the the
metal grills look differently in the
different spaces I heard very often that
the metal grill is there to keep the
frame from video footage of this and
I'll show using that footage later but
that's kind of further along the process
and there's a transition
methodologically not only do they make
vows of poverty chastity obedience and
enclosure they observe monastic silence
meaning that they only talk and say
what's necessary to complete a task and
then they are quiet for the rest of the
day for one hour in the evening they
have a communal recreation period and
they can talk freely but that doesn't
mean that everybody gets the chance to
talk as a sign of their extreme poverty
they give up shoes so some of the
photographs you'll see them wearing
shoes they do wear shoes usually when
they work outside and they do make a lot
of exceptions as a nun ages
she wears shoes or sandals but generally
they do give up shoes
we're not holding it we were striving to
become fully morally past me to know our
destination is happening although I do
see that this is a suburb of heaven the
community but nevertheless it's not a
camping you know when I can't be on
forever
we're passing through even in this
suburb of heaven it's not heaven yet
it's so therefore I'm traveling we're
all pilgrims coming to that perfect
union which is heaven and we don't know
each of us don't know when that time
will be for us
the project started with world history
and I waited until I was invited in to
make photographs I let them know that I
was interested in making photographs and
then I waited for them to invite me in
the grill the metal grill there is a
literal and symbolic separation from our
world in the outside world and really
that's so that the nuns can be holy
given over to God and fulfill their
missions their care is to pray for
Humanity so they have what I club is
like a prayer hotline it's this number
that the public cause a lot of people in
this town where the monastery is were
introduced to the monastery of carrots
their mom brought them there they asked
for prayers they would call for prayers
and so the nun is a few of the nuns have
the role of taking the phone calls and
then all of the nuns seven times a day
during the Divine Office and the Liturgy
of the hours they pray for personal
tragedies and global catastrophes the
Mother Abbess so I've had this question
a lot about the insider-outsider dynamic
and the world seeps in in these
different ways like through the prayer
hotline and then also through a
newspaper the Mother Abbess gets the
newspaper she'll read it and she'll let
the community know if there's something
that they should pray about she always
tells them if there's been a murder in
the community and that they pray about
that they live in a 25,000 square foot
monastery a series of buildings really
it's kind of
and it sits on a 14-acre
dated premises this is a photograph that
I made in their woodshop I sure did
because I've been asked a lot about my
expectations versus what I found I
expected a lot more mysticism than I
encountered and even when I made this
photograph the one on the right is the
novice mistress and one on the left was
a novice at the time and I became very
close to both of them over the years and
after we're making the photograph is so
beautiful like the dust is just glowing
it's there gorgeous it's like magical
and the sign on the right said ah it's a
magic touch it's holy dust they just
started laughing about how and then the
one in the last day I sign that you're
about to become a saint you know it to
her novice mistress and to me it was
just kind of indicative of or an example
of how they take their lives and their
vows very very seriously
they don't take themselves for each
other or me very seriously at all
there's a lightness that I didn't I
didn't expect
the nuns as part of the Divine Office
wake at midnight and I'm going to have a
schedule on here that I can show you if
you guys are interested in knowing the
exact schedule but they wake at midnight
they go to sleep wait for about 4 hours
wait get midnight pray go back to sleep
and awake again there's this whole idea
of being awake and praying for the world
while the rest of the world is sleeping
this is in the boiler the nuns are very
self-sufficient they learn how to do a
lot of the care of the monastery
themselves so she's cleaning out the
boiler
so these photographs as I came to I
think it was a really good process that
the photographs came later I came to
understand quite a bit about their
culture before going in and making the
photographs and really had in my mind
this kind of Dutch the Dutch paintings
as I was making these photographs
I worked in the nursing home from the
time I graduated till about right before
Christmas my aunt in California who is
also my godmother invited me to spend
Christmas with her before I entered the
monastery so I quit my job in December
and I think it was in my visit my aunt
and uncle and my cousins and then that
was interesting too that was I was just
struggling I can remember so my aunt was
talking to me now are you sure than any
location don't you ever feel like you
wanna get in here I said well I I
couldn't go that way then she said well
it's just fun of you don't have a
location and my other aunt said you know
that's not a sign that society that
she's a woman yes she could still have a
location with and you know it's like my
aunt was worried worried about me
becoming a man so I think that as kind
of this was fairly early on in the
process that this interview took place
and
in this particular clip I think you can
hear a little bit of the hesitation as
she's starting to recall memories that
it doesn't come out quickly at first it
comes out haltingly and then the
memories start coming together like
because they observe monastic silence
because they really seek anonymity they
rarely talk about their lives so doing
these oral history interviews that was
one of the first things that I noticed
like within a half an hour
the voices started getting hoarse it was
it was kind of a process of unfolding
during these interviews and it takes
years it takes six years for a woman
before she makes final vows and it's
this slow steady integration into the
community who ended up being nerd in my
own involvement in this project like I
told I was in Switzerland and spoke at a
couple schools and I said it to the
students I I needed to take six years to
learn about the culture not before
writing about it and they said it took
six years and I hadn't thought about it
before but it takes that exact amount of
time for a woman to go through the
process of formation one year of
postulants two years as a novice three
years of temporary vows before she would
make final vows and it just so happened
that it mirrored that kind of a
structure
initially when I was making photographs
because they prized their hiddenness I
tried to not photograph them directly
based on there are a few few photographs
from the photographic series that are
straight in their faces I did end up
making portraits of them of their faces
later on but I really tried to respect
their their desire for hiddenness and
anonymity this is so much of this
process with I mean it was just such a
learning experience like when I was in
there one time in making photographs the
nun who was leading me around
was holding this piece of paper and I
looked down and I asked her what these
little sign is worth and she said that
those are their marks each woman before
she even has a new religious name which
happens during the closing ceremony a
year after she has entered when she
first enters the Mother Abbess assigns
her a mark and this is for practical
purposes but it reflects some aspect of
her character or spiritual quality so
does line over there that looks like
maybe aflame metal sphere and then this
one is an anchor and then sometimes they
have a letter from the name Claire or
Francis or
Colet so that's what the see is and this
is the order of who was responsible for
taking me from place to place and I was
making photographs so the spear was a
server and anchor was a reader during
the meal
this a lot of time is what the nuns
would say is that it is meant to be a
strict life it's meant to be a hard life
and they say that the vows crucify you
on the obedience yes it does it's a
crucifixion obedient system but that's
where where else you can be able to give
it all if it doesn't cost anything you
know it doesn't make a very good story
anyway you know you know you want to
watch the stories of the movies where
someone had to struggle and work hard if
he just went and did everything without
any effort it'd be kind of bullying you
know and he'd be an unreal Superman he
would you know even Jesus it's he being
God he didn't show us that way and it's
a good thing he did because then we
never get arrested you know but he took
our weaknesses and he worked with their
human weakness and so we stopped do it
will help us to do so is part of the
monastic customs one aspect is their
indirect form of communication rarely
would a superior say to a novice or to
another nine do this
it's always an invitation an invitation
to obey to obedience so one of the
knives she was a novice at the time to
tell me the story of how she I mean I
was being integrated all of these women
were expatriates from our world and so
they had been through this process and
so they were teaching me what they had
already learned she told me that
she learns the hard way she was sitting
next to the novice mistress they're
seated by rank in a rectangular shaped
room in the refectory when they eat and
it's by rank the youngest by rank here
all the way over to the oldest by right
and the rank is when they entered the
community and so she was seated over
here next to the novice mistress and the
novice misters said to her you may take
there was a a potato left and a full
potato and the novice mister said you
may take the full potato well she wasn't
hungry enough to take the full potato so
she took half and then she found out
that you may is actually taking this is
kind of jumping ahead looping it
forwarded back but at the very beginning
this project did not unfold perfectly at
the very beginning one of the first
important meetings that I had was with a
young woman back in 2005 who was going
to the monastery considering joining
she's not part of the book because she
didn't join the monastery until 2011 she
joined after six years of discernment
but I was standing there I'd asked if I
could be a fly in the wall and this
story kind of illustrates it's one of
these illustrations of my math
methodological transition so it has to
be a fly on the wall I just thought I
would be an observer who wasn't making
any kind of impact on the situation and
taking pictures and making notes and
about half an hour into their dialogue I
asked a question just to clarify
something and the Mother Abbess looked
at me and she said a fly on the wall a I
wish I had a swatter and I was like done
that first and then I covered my mouth
and I just started laughing
and then she started smiling and but it
was a very quick and the most one of the
most direct forms of communication they
ever had with me to the point but it was
a very good quick early lesson in do
what I say I'm gonna do stay in the
background this is something that kept
with me for the rest of the project yeah
the project evolved to the point where
they would invite me to different events
this is a photograph of a woman 9 quit
just died she had Alzheimer's for a
number of years she had served during
World War two and then she became a nun
in an active order and then transferred
to the cloistered monastery and this
private the project transitioned from
being me approaching man with this
question you know trying to understand
their life which is so different than
what I am experiencing out in the world
and so different from this culture of
people seeking the limelight looking for
the my light being hidden away but the
project transition to really then kind
of seeking me out and this is one of
those key moments where when his nun
died the Mother Abbess called me and
asked if I would like to come and
photograph the funeral service which
would have military honors for this
veteran from the rooftop of the
monastery and to me that's one of those
markers within the project where the
authority was kind of shifted and it
became much more of a collaboration and
then working with me as collaborators in
this process
so this is just after the funeral
service and you can see the cats get
there in the back
are there questions so far I'm gonna
keep going oh go ahead
I'm yet I just had a couple of question
one of my two very important questions
that I had that only the restfully it's
how we definitely did you attack writing
the narrative because it's infected to
delicate balance between journalism
narrative in oral history law it's
keeping the order well earlier group
students somebody had asked me about how
I edited the work and I said I didn't
tamper with the words so much and I
clarified it Amy after the break I said
you know I should really clarify I was
not changing the words I was focused on
leaving the words as much as possible as
they spoke them so it isn't as they
would have written it but if that's you
would hear them saying it it's not in
the order that they would have said it
though I restructured it in a narrative
form and those are those those calling
sections though where it's just their
own words but unique though you didn't
you didn't feel like you were tackling
or having to you know tackle internally
with yourself between what it is I could
try there you know I guess expressed and
realizing that you deal
with religion and having what they're
telling you at which or what they want
the story that you're trying to tell
where you feel like you were having some
internal trouble or trying to tell the
story or I would say that the struggle
would have come before I started writing
because I'm not Catholic and so they had
to have their hat to me this this
process just like they go through a
process of discernment to find out where
they truly belong is this the monastery
that I have a calling from God I think
this is what they're saying
the calling from God I need to find out
where it is that this calling fix from I
had to go through this kind of
discernment process of understanding
aspects of their culture which is
totally linked to their religion so I
had this immersion process of them
explaining different aspects of their
life and I had where as opportunities
and took them to go back and say what
does this mean
explain this does that answer your
question yeah
so as far as what initially brought me
there I just did for college write an
article the way that I remember it is
that there were there was a trend of
young Italian women going back to the
habit and as I remember it some of these
women were the daughters of fashion
designers and so I became really hooked
on this question or this fascination
kind of with not only departed culture
but departed family history what would
compel a young woman my age to make such
a drastic countercultural decision in
her life so when I lived in or worked in
different communities I would reach out
to different religious orders kind of
gauging whether there would be it would
be a good fit this community ended up
being a really perfect fit for a number
of reasons if we can go through those
later on but when I first I know that a
lot of people are interested in this
question of access and how why the nuns
agreed to do that so when I first
approached the mother added I said I
would completely transparent that
Catholic I had just lived on a ship for
a year in Africa a hospital ship worked
in the communications department I was
interested in the idea of an enclosed a
community within an enclosed space and
how that functions these were some of
the initial interest and I also said you
know newspaper articles were coming out
in the new york times about monasteries
closing I said it seems that the number
of nuns is dropping and
she said back to me nuns are and she
used this phrase erased from the
landscape and she was referring to a
couple of things in that conversation
she was referring to after Vatican two
active nuns who were nurses and teachers
weren't wearing the traditional habit
they weren't going back to have it they
were allowed to like we're just straight
clothes so active nuns were erased from
the landscape because we out in the
public weren't seen being able to
identify them either habit but also
she's talking about cloistered
contemplatives because when they join
the monastery they very rarely leave
except for very so like doctors cake
house cause they vote by absentee ballot
so they were very rarely seen and then
when the nun dies she's buried on the
premises with the stone that marks her
religious name and her death day not her
birth name and not her birth date so
those were some of the initial starting
points
me identifying you know I think the
numbers are dropping and what they did
was then pray about it
she prayed with there's a an elected
council there's the Mother Abbess and
then there's the bickerings and then
there's the rest of the elected council
and these members are called
discreet because they're supposed to be
discreet so she prayed about it and the
community or the council prayed about it
and then they took it to the rest of the
community and they prayed about it and
then several years passed I I did visit
on occasion but it really picked up
steam after I came to Summer Institute
here at Columbia some of the nuns for
example the one the romantic encounter
would work within the hierarchy of the
monastery to meet with me additional
times for these oral history interviews
she was very sociable she described
herself as sociable and she would for
example tell the Mother Abbess if Abby
wants to meet me again I'm totally
available and then she would say to me
tell the Mother Abbess if you want to
meet with me again because that's how it
worked it flowed through the Mother
Abbess
from my background and understanding of
oral history I really embrace the
philosophy of cooperation and shared
Authority the focus was really on their
individual stories and their motivations
and their memories and their
perspectives and they're going to play a
few of these audio clips I would like to
also show you some of the video footage
ok so this is the voice
she's now mother Maria damn right
by Inglot I was going to do it at the
age of 12 it's great that you know I
knew that it's just a matter of time
because the couldn't enter the convent
at six great thing so I had to wait
three years and mom if I said when you
change your mind you would change their
mind to then when she found out I did
the funny thing two issues well you know
you're going to always have to wear a
dress
it doesn't matter that's a hair but
that's not a dress because I wasn't one
to wear dresses I was very active and
you get a lot of opinions to those kinds
of things and doesn't want to sit around
you know the other things she would say
to see you you couldn't have to get up
at 5:00 every morning now that was a
really stickler because I like to sleep
but that doesn't matter
you know because I just know it doesn't
matter what I have to give up you know I
didn't think so much about keeping up I
just knew that I was going to be here
isn't it that was more on my mind rather
than school as my mom that would still
put this other stuff asking and it's
good that she did you know made me think
no no it did not take care of itself you
know
I mean I was kind of in the first week
now it's making percentages and
everything else that the other sisters
in the deficient you know my nickname
was sister Kathy lot because I was
countin income in Compton and I really
meant I come for other people too I do
that just for myself but because I think
it's a wonderful thing and I think it's
exciting and you know I I didn't do this
out in the world but I never had
anything to look forward to as much as
this and something that I really think
he's really a department so I yes I was
you know because it's the it's been a
draining for me for you know it was 15
years it was a dream for me to be our
Lord spouse and so finally I really so
one of the things that I didn't expect
with this much humor as I encountered
I'm not gonna play this audio clip but I
will just say that this was a novice
mistress and I explained to her that an
outsider who would take statues from the
monastery and bring them to her house
and repair them I could interviewed her
and she hits that what surprised her was
learning the ages of the nuns so I asked
the number the novice misters her age
that I'm 32 and I also went through that
of being completely astounded over the
mines as I learned the older nuns ages
and she said there's a secret the veil
covers a lot it covers the great hair
and the double chin but she said there's
also the aspects that they're removed
from the stresses that we encounter in
the world
and there's just a lot of joy so people
also want to know about what they've
given up a lot of the nuns talked about
that they had not expected this calling
that they had wanted to become mothers
they wanted to get married and they
wanted to have children again this this
audio with this particular nun this is
the mother she was mother Miriam she's
not the vigorish she reached her term
limit and then so she's the vicar's now
and then after she can be voted back
this is another evidence but it's a
little scratch attrition is playing with
the mic a little bit I'll just summarize
basically she was saying she was the
youngest of a host Lou of children and
she always wanted to become a mother and
for a long time she wondered
she was grappling with this
philosophical question of how can I deny
these children life and she ended up
coming to this conclusion that if God
had called her to this he never intended
those children to be born another 9 mr.
Nicolay who I became very close to she
was one of the first tests I think after
I met with the Mother Abbess the Mother
Abbess arranged for me to meet with
sister Nikolai and this is an alias that
she chose for herself so sister
Nicolette was raised to Mara
her dad brought the family there he was
a Fulbright Scholar and so she was
raised and looked into shining in
Switzerland and Italy she's fluent in 4
languages she wanted to become either a
pilot or a flight attendant and she was
surprised but shouldn't go with her
friends she went with her friends
retreated to the poor Claire monastery
and she talks there's section I could
sit in the book where she says I got my
calling through a lie because her
friends said we know where we can go on
a retreat there's this monastery
district monastery and so they called in
the Mother Abbess said we don't just
take women who just need a retreat but
if you're actually considering this as
your vocation you can come and so he
said oh yeah we're considering it so
they let them come and the other two
friends a sister Nicolette were sisters
biological sisters and they took
applications sister neglect didn't but
she started to believe during that visit
that this was her calling it was
something she was fighting with because
being so proficient at languages and
having an understanding of Latin and
being claustrophobic she says in an
elevator she says that she didn't think
she could live in a cloister because
enclosure cloister claustrophobia all
have the same Latin root so for some of
them an obstacle was their own their own
personality and for her it was this just
like with them weather
it was the question of this
philosophical question I'm denying
children live for sister Nicolette it
was like does God really no need does he
know my personality like this is not
something I can do but she eventually
came to the conclusion that if God was
calling her to this he was actually
going to give her the grace to carry it
out and all of them would say that
without the calling you could never live
this life it's so very difficult
I'm gonna pray it's all about a
relationship with God is if it starting
line it really it can just had to
summarize it all it would just come down
to that and it's all about our
relationship with God and that's
beautiful so you're bearing fruit I love
the point about like spiritual
motherhood that you know where the
spouses of Christ is another name for
ancestors and our fruitfulness in the
church is to bear spiritual children and
we're like the vows of poverty chastity
obedience and enclosure it's all like
freeing us it's like a freeing of the
whole person from all of the those
things that will be contrary to the vows
you know so it's not it's not like
like something that's like restricting
you know closure it's not restricting
either person it's almost like well I
think the hardest when they got home you
know you weren't there we were to a new
life and you're thinkin
each day is new you know I need to say
you make something new and we are left
with the emptiness you know makes you
first letter I think once they once they
have wristlets and they come you know
they didn't chest it they just need well
I think what the heart is when they got
home you know you weren't there we went
to a new life and you're kickin each day
is new with the deputies you know it
makes you first letter right I think
what's day
what say you have visits and they come
you know then they take it adjusted they
realize if you're after then they're
happy it just it's just a supernatural
forget the bells and you have to you
know you have to something I realized it
that there is stuff afterlife gotta get
rewarded and you look like it gonna be
nice it's gonna be wonderful all
followed you came will come too so this
one I accidentally jumped ahead I was
asking her it's like this paradox of
being detached from the world that also
deeply connected to it and caring for
and she said yes that's exactly what it
is we leave the world in order to be for
the world and this last one that's the
eldest not vibrating she's been there
for I just figured it out before the
talk I want to be sure exactly how many
years she's been in there she's been in
over sixty four years she entered June
29th 1950 and she's still seeing like I
don't think I've ever adjusted it's just
so difficult I mean one of the ways that
they kind of slowly integrate is because
they wake at midnight what they do is
over the months and and a day so that
they don't immediately jump into this
totally different schedule when they
first enter but they slowly let them
integrate and they actually added a year
to formation because it's they just were
noticing it's so difficult the world
that the young women were coming from
was so different from the
that they had come from into the
monastery it was such a difficult
transition so they added a year at dis
monastery so that the none of the young
women had more time to adapt at each of
the stages from postulant to novice to
temporary vows each member of the
community has a vote whether or not that
woman can proceed to the next stage the
woman also decides whether or not she
will proceed and really and the Mother
Abbess has a lot of discretion that she
can in the first two stages and just
send somebody home if she really doesn't
think that the woman belongs there are
bits there but they used to vote with
black and white marbles or stones and
now that you vote yes or no it's a
simple majority are there any questions
so far
okay so I want to show you some of this
video footage by um I can take your
question before showing you if there's
anything relating to what I just yeah
what do you mean by adding in here oh so
it used to be five years of formation
okay and then they added you an extra
year seven six years before they make
final vows because once they make final
vows they would have to appeal to Rome
before they could leave like before they
would be allowed to actually and it's a
people enclosure so they report to to
Rome to the Holy See
No so when I conducted the oral history
interviews we would usually sit this is
the upstairs partner and it's their
square bars and this is the parlor where
they visit with their families usually
so I would sit and slide the microphone
through into the oral history interviews
there all of those photographs that I
did are inside of the enclosure and then
the young woman who you just saw
speaking into the camera I met her in
2005 I wanted to follow somebody through
that liminal phase of transitioning from
one identity individually and socially
and culturally into the monastery I
interviewed her for years and years
she's not in the book because she didn't
join the monastery until 2011 that whole
time I didn't know if she was gonna join
she didn't know if she was going to join
she ended up joining I always felt like
when I was doing oral history interviews
with her I always felt that there was
something holding her back like she
wasn't her family wasn't supportive but
I didn't know what was really holding
her back if it was something with me
being the mediator and I or what it was
so I decided two years ago started
deciding to give her a video camera she
was a painter she'd been a blogger
before she entered I knew she was
visually astute she had seen when I was
pretty
see i kept showing them the photographs
that i was making so they knew what my
aesthetic sense was and so i basically
kind of was proposing this idea of and i
went through a head to go through the
hierarchical chain of what if I'm not
the mediator what if this video camera
is what if this video camera is
operating as if it's her eyes
encountering her world and so I
basically operated here as a director
saying can you document the material
culture like of your daily life can you
make impressionistic beautiful images
it's moving images and can you make dye
eristic which speak into the camera I
didn't give her specific instructions of
speak into it this particular way I love
that being a product of social media she
speaks into it in like confessional way
it's kind of a very familiar and a trope
that were so that's how that evolved and
I didn't know what would evolve you know
but I was completely blown away by you
know she's so much more free speaking
into the camera than she had ever been
when I had been interviewing her six
years but I mean granted she was in a
very certain psychological state of my
family's not supporting me I don't know
where I belong I have called her family
wanted her to finish college and then
she had college debt and then she
couldn't find a job and then so she had
much freer now that she's in the
monastery and she's a little bit settled
there's that to be considered as
thank you very much
isolation things that was struck by when
I read something peaches is important
for us they share with you information
they might not have paralyzed or spoke
to each other
hi and she is so given the context given
the social institution which they're
trying to socialize each year given the
potential possibility also transmission
how does this community
okay issues and how
sure so I guess there's three different
answers to this one is that in this
process of educating me about their
community even also sussing me out they
gave me a book to read and it was a book
about monks and this this book the
account is pretty harrowing of you know
one of them goes through like takes the
self-flagellation way too far
the nuns have read this and they gave it
to me to read this is not a practice
that they espouse but they wanted me to
understand what else has been written
and understand also like how other
people are interpreting monastic life a
second part a second answer is that they
did one in particular shared some
emotionally difficult stuff that orally
through protocol is you share the oral
history transcripts and they it's a
shared authority they this is their
story so I didn't include that in the
book at her request the third thing I
would say is that
the she is now with the Mother Abbess
she was the vigorous at the time the
book was written Maria do Gradius the
name she chose she did work it was a
psychiatric nurse for a time I would say
it was either her or the old mother it
was the former Mother Abbess who said in
the past there was a saying or thinking
that holiness its wholeness and she
doesn't agree with that
she thinks that basically in essence
humans are flawed and there's the
striving for wholeness I would say that
the current Mother Abbess and talking
with the two of them they're very aware
of mental health issues and that's
something that they would definitely be
on the lookout for and also that as a
woman integrates into the community
that's something that they would be
aware of they don't they don't like the
current mother ever since we're not
looking for numbers not looking to add
numbers to our community we're looking
for people who actually have a calling
and you fit and you belong here if they
don't belong it's not
you know it's not a place for people who
are trying to escape that's a question a
lot of people ask me in distress what
are they escaping it seem like they're
escaping you couldn't live it they say
if you didn't have a colony if you have
the grace of God if you had yeah
yeah I mean it's it's changed me I was
saying personally and methodologically I
adapted my methods because of my work
with them I would say to the obvious
personal instances that I was in a car
in 2009 on my way to the monastery broke
my back had a compression factor in my
vertebrae that out - and I didn't
realize until I visited the monastery
after that happened how much I had
become a part of their community and
when I was visiting there couple weeks
after the accident one of the knives
pulled me aside and said that they had
been praying for me since the day I
first visited and that she was praying
for me that morning because I was
enroute there to the patron saint of
travelling see Christopher for my safety
and I even had to me incredibly to it's
an incredible thing that they made these
concessions I think and allowed me into
the world like that has totally impacted
me and the relationships that developed
have totally changed me and the current
Mother Abbess the mother Maria day of
gradius
I'm I I think she's I mean I really
trust their judgement like it's theirs
I've talked to them about everything I
just really think this she has a really
grounded super interesting perspective
like they're all talking to you and not
to each other so this nun who I became
she she's one that I became very close
to sister Nicola she was she's one of
the descries because she's the novice
mistress so she was one of the first
ones to read the book because the
discretes reddick this is how it's
supposed to work the discretes read it
and then the rest of the community
community and so when I visited I was
you know I wanted them to like the book
so she I've visited with her and she
said this is true she said everything
you've written about us is true
it's us without our makeup on and I'm
living a human
but yeah and then there was one I heard
from the Mother Abbess that one of the
nuns took issue at the beginning with it
the very internal it's like one of the
first line she read the rest of the book
but this is what she took issue with
then I described what she was wearing
and revealing but she showed me the
photo and she was the only nine who ever
in a direct kind of way commented on the
way I was dressed and I'm glad she did
but she basically the thing that what I
was wearing was too revealing to go into
the monastery she said and so I talked
to sister nickel at after that you know
when I say she said you have to
understand this is mr. Nicolay we only
ever see each other's hands and faces so
seeing any part of anybody's you know
seeing your neck is like more than we
ever seen that's revealing so I didn't
think she would that's the last thing I
thought she would say if it was because
she brought this photo out to me and
said look at the way I used to dress I
wore makeup and I wore these like loci
things well now she's saying she didn't
but they are the Mother Abbess also said
that it's learning about one another's
lives they're learning about their
community
I'm too quick question you had spoken
earlier today about memory and I wanted
to know what were some of the problems
that you had and then one of many things
the interviews that you conducted with a
all life history or whether the Matic
especially in have the younger woman and
why I'm thinking was in her 20s because
if she was in school at the time how
exactly did you conduct a life history
and you lived her so your question is
what kind of interview study yeah with
their life history or automatic or was
it like a mixture of both interview
styles in order to get a more
well-rounded picture as to who these
women work and then what was some of the
issues that you had working with their
memory knowing that they're pretty much
silent 23 hours of the day except when a
framer wouldn't have an hour of our
consumption right well as far as like
the memory like that the romantic
encounter desk I think the most obvious
example that I could bring to show of
like the memory starts haltingly and
then they rip it you know there's this
emotional visceral memory that they grip
onto and they were there and then it
just kind of tumbles out and she
recounts it pretty vividly she knows
where she was what happened the
interviews were usually initially
biographical life history and then we do
repeat interviews I've met many many
times with the Mother Abbess with the
novice mistress with the vigorous to
kind of fill in the gaps with different
things
so the only I should clarify there's one
scene basically that one non-shared and
then a few weeks later when we might
said I don't it was from her use didn't
want it out there even though they had
aliases just didn't want it and that's
the only thing that was omitted I gave
them transcripts throughout the process
that's oral history protocol that giving
them transcripts of the interviews and
said and as part of the Contras like the
leaves the during release in the
contract you know they would add to it
like with additional interviews to
clarify things if they wanted so they
all read all their transcripts and I
will say that there's I think there were
two nuns who came back one corrected to
pronouns for me it's the Marion sisters
a and not Owen was one of them and then
the other one wrote out more descriptive
this is what I meant
this is you know that's kind of a thing
it didn't change at all really it just
enhanced the interview
totally totally no and actually I talked
to my editor and asked her if she would
recommend them reading it and she said
no so they read all the transcripts and
I gave those to now this is 2014 I gave
those to them starting in 2009 so they
had years to look over the transpose
my
so he's wondering you know with my
homework I thought you had work within
the customs
I mean I think that if I
I mean honestly it kind of felt like the
process unfolded intuitively and I mean
actually like I learned about different
things and then I respected that I
learned that they value anonymity and so
it was either I or the mother I can't
remember which proposed family assets
you know it's just it's a small measure
but it it it gets at that underlying
hiddenness you know or the one not
pointed out like if you're not so
modestly dressed so I started dressing
way more modestly like I was never
wearing low-cut top so when I went there
to begin with but I I started going
wearing way more modest like not showing
anything below here you know and black
all the time and and I honestly looking
back that was probably one of those
important markers before they invited me
to enter into the enclosure like they're
very astute like they were looking back
I can see this like they're watching my
integration and my respect my grasp of
what they value
I think that was one of the identifiers
you discussed that you you use the
cameras and we hit em you gave it to the
one woman to really record and do she
the name said that worked out well but
before you try to that we've had all the
way apprehensive you're giving so much
of your you know control you're not
sitting there asking questions but
you're you're giving all of the focus to
someone to see what what they would like
to focus on were you worried that maybe
a want to be what you were looking for
it would be something completely
unuseful and were you mostly just
thinking that's a great question but
I'll just say like these whole eight
years like everything has been at risk I
had no idea at the outset what I was
going to make whether or not they would
agree he's it's like when one series of
risks after another and I just thought
let's just see you know but I will also
add that I was talking to Cameron
earlier about where I come to oral
history from is this perspective that in
oral history in still photographs and in
video we all undertake performances so
in the oral histories they were sharing
with me what they wanted to share you
know with the still photographs they
were bringing me I would ask when I
learned about different things
oh can you show me this occasionally
that but and then they were saying do
you want to photograph the roof that
kind of
but they were showing me what they
wanted to show me
it is a negotiation you know the video
camera is no different it just embeds
that materially you can see how they
engage with the camera where you can't
see that in still photographs you can
hear that a little bit in oral histories
when I play my question and their answer
but honestly the video footage to answer
your question is way better than I hoped
for I knew that she was aesthetically
trained but the footage is gorgeous and
then she is way more open way more
vulnerable than I expected she's very
comfortable holding that video camera
and sharing her thoughts that way so you
have a background in journalism in oral
history and interest in ethnography
what do you might say something about
how this particular experience impacted
you as an interviewer unlike a question
sure well I did after college I worked
as an investigative reporter and clearly
I had an agenda going into those
interviews specific things I was looking
for with the oral history interviews I
loved in coming to oral history that it
is so open to the motivations and and it
acknowledges that memory is faulty in a
way that journalism kind of doesn't
really address
what was does that answer your question
how does it change my that's partially
getting at it I mean but everything so
I'm curious with you know these
backgrounds this background they have in
these different fields thinking about
all of those different areas of
experience how did this experience
working you know in this monastic
setting impact you as an interviewer in
terms of what sort of questions you ask
when your silence especially coming from
a background where you're in
investigative journalism there's been
more of a full-court press style of
interview yeah I mean my this whole
project slowed me down in so many
different ways but it also kind of made
me realize like journalism is good for
certain purposes oral history is good
for certain purposes it came up short
for me with the subject of this film in
progress
those oral history interviews I'm still
gonna use some of them in the film and
they do get excerpts but it didn't get
at the transition and okay the way that
giving her the video camera did so for
me it's been this transition of my
professors probably would say a
transition of the power dynamic you know
from being totally in control as the
journalist to shared authorship with
oral history to giving them the video
camera all the way through its
performances that are constructive for a
viewer truly but my role has kind of
shifted and I really think that it just
um this was a natural progression I
wouldn't have said now I'm gonna do this
but it just kind of evolved that way and
I don't think I could have done this
without having done that like it it had
to happen
she wouldn't be as free in the video if
I hadn't been working with her for her
since 2005 and there was that trust and
then have been working with her
community and she trusted her Mother
Abbess for Mother Abbess trusted me this
is a really good question I've had a lot
of time to reflect on different aspects
of this I haven't I haven't reflected on
that I don't have a good answer for that
I think I proposed it like I would over
the years propose different things they
pray about it I give them a space they
decide whether or not to do it all of
the nuns that I conducted oral history
interviews with I did make portraits of
they all wanted to do it I don't have a
very good answer yeah you need to speak
about how you approached Oxford and what
materials you've had when you approach
them and whether you approached other
publishers I saw I did simultaneous
submission after I've written the
manuscript with nothing
yeah well pretty much I did revisions
but you have to tell them straight up if
you're doing
question I think I can't remember to be
honest which department initially
pitched it - she liked that editor liked
it but it wasn't a good fit to that
department it was either history
religion I can't remember I didn't know
that they had an oral history series I
feel like this whole project is like
didn't know enough but okay so I spoke
at Oh Marc the Orlan sternum in Atlantic
region conference in 2010 I guess it was
and the series added her is that when
his try to lift I think if the series
editor was there and once I know he's
senior advisor which I spoke to him then
it kind of went through pretty quickly
through the oral history series which
was a really good thing
have a thank you is fundamental tension
that describe to you the reality of
their lives their constant striving to
be that perfect person to serve God the
reality and
how do they negotiate so it's very
individual you know it's one of them is
sister Nicolette sighs this is her quote
I was talking to her about the idea
versus the reality and she said we were
just having this discussion they had
somebody else said they're distinct
they're separate but she thinks that the
reality is they're they're tights better
the reality and the ideal go together
what's the question let me give it the
question again we into the first
question first immunity so the goal
mother Maria day of granny I says is to
become a saint every day collectively
they say together I'm sorry
they say this to one another they say
this to God I'm sorry for any way that I
have offended you
there's this constant recognition that
they are human and yet they are striving
for something that is a supernatural
kind of existence for me this was part
of the pull to the project these women
in happening at heterotopia it's in a
sense neither here nor there they're
partly on earth I'm really serving as
intermediaries
it's this unseen realm that they're
living for within this rich material
culture so they're very aware of the
paradoxes the complications their
humanity but the constant striving and
that God will help them do it only by
the grace of God can mean two-way
Michelle
like this
in tension
and
I just think I mean there are so many
ways that could answer that and I think
one of them is that this is something I
couldn't let go of like I just really
fundamentally believed that these first
the stories were valuable it was a
different perspective than what I would
otherwise and so I thought it was
valuable I also really found it
personally gratifying because I became
attached to these women developed
relationships and then I would say that
intellectually it was super stimulating
like these paradoxes and trying to
understand how these different it's a
very complicated kind of world and I
found it totally station as I learn
different aspects of it I think too that
there are ways that I fit with this
project that not even knowing about
moistured monasteries when I first
started the project not knowing that
they still existed but I was my parents
moved us kids from Chicago to a small
rural town when I was young and it's a
very insular community it's a farming a
farming town mostly German so we my dad
was raised Jewish my parents raised us
Protestant I had a lot of training and
just growing up in dealing with an
insular
at the very beginning I wanted to told
you that's why I saw it makes people out
but I think that that helped me that it
cooked me with the skills yeah
you mean financially
you know I mean I think kind of early on
when I I told a few people about the
project when I was here at Columbia with
you for this Summer Institute that was
one of the turning points were not
knowing that this really kind of hadn't
been done so that kind of was a driving
force but people like Peter McGuire who
taught at thee and shoot he's an oral
history and Steve Rowland these people
were like mentors to me throughout the
process so I would reach out to them and
say ask them a question and/or get
feedback not very often but I did reach
out to them they were amazing Mentors
yeah just
oh I did all of it I did all the
transcribing yeah with a past project
much smaller the local hospital had
donated their transcribers to do all the
transcriptions but with this I wanted to
do the transcribing I really kind of
wanted to to seep in and and also I mean
there's practical reasons like to really
hear it a second time to improve my
interviewing skills when I go back make
all of that like active listening
I basically I basically was working jobs
to and near the monastery so that I
couldn't do the project when I made the
exhibit I did a Kickstarter campaign and
that paid for the expenses of framing
the exhibit I didn't cover my time or
anything like that
she stayed with them
mostly can you again this is part of the
like respecting the separateness I did
stay over I didn't stay when I stayed
over I didn't stay in the enclosure I
stayed in the guest quarters that either
a family member would stay in or
somebody considering joining and I said
you're really interesting you know we've
talked you know recently in the program
about the idea that the whole sort of
oral history and legal release now such
this premise for this idea that each
person is like an individual with full
autonomy that can consent to things and
you know that a legal person is the same
thing as a you know fully complicated
human person and you know there's
reading the book I thought is really
interesting that that they all kind of
had to consent to it especially the
Mother Abbess had to consent and then
one of the sisters was like well I don't
really want to do this I don't want to
talk to her that you tell me if I should
talk to her if you told me to do it I'll
do it
and so this kind of process of group
consenting you know that they even give
up some of their authority over this
process is really anything is
interesting there that was really
interesting and there's a couple things
to say about that one is that um so that
particular nine who did that became a
major advocate for this project because
she would go back to the other ones and
say you should do she and then they
would come to me and say and I
know about I knew this that they would
come to me and say we heard that you're
not like a typical journalist is like
endorsement to do that interviews I
didn't interview all of them
I interviewed whoever chose to take part
this did not in the video
she's a pasta just became a novice the
Mother Abbess this is kind of in
contrast to that comment of like giving
up authority I don't know how much when
I gave her the video camera authority
shifted she was admitted into places
within the monastery she had never been
to video there she also was her schedule
shifted her duties changed she was
allowed to staff later to do video and
editing so this was after this is a
separate part from the book like the
book is like Lily oral history you know
grounded in oral history methodology the
film project really is this
anthropological collaborative
ethnographic work where there are
different schools of thought of and
maybe I won't get into that right now
because I probably be able to cite it
correctly with the video camera for
those purposes let me think for a second
and then I
I'll try to side a this is a totally
different project in giving them the
video camera there's this maybe if I can
pull up and then I can start it there's
this idea of individuals and communities
going through a ritual of rebellion and
in particular in Africa where women are
not given much authority generally this
one took their community there's a
ceremonial ritual in which for a few
days
the women act out in aggression and and
basically it's an up ending of the
dynamics of social dynamics and the
women can act out and then basically at
the end of this ritual it goes back to
normal and I learned about that in grad
school during an apology and then when I
gave them the video camera not intending
to do that but knowing that the camera
can change things but not planning to
incite but it really I came
it was in a sense a ritual of rebellion
authority shifted everything shifted for
a short time but then when I went and
collected the video cameras I I said
really you know how will I change I said
it'll go back to my shoes here it is
next which will be Dyan
I wanted one other questions you may not
be able to answer this but is women what
they talk about in their hour and
recreation and if you had any sense that
the process of stories with you machine
before reading the button it changed at
all what they talk about soon at our
expense
my mother their hours of recreation
several different and a lot of it is
telling so they'll tell us some of those
collective history stories like the
lessons learned from so for example they
would tell the story of two nights early
on didn't really get along well they
were they were tasked with working in
the garden together one day one of them
that's put you know marvels of rocks in
her pockets and then walked out and then
when the other one started talking to
start putting markers in her mouth to
keep herself from speaking back
they were tell stories like that but
they would also tell some of their
family stories I think one time they
were talking about the names
there
great-nephew seems like that
to get time for but okay so I really was
curious because I wanted to know so I
sought out a woman who had joined and
left and interviewed her it is very
common and I'll come back and explain
that a little bit more about her
particular but it is very common because
the community describes this as a
discerning process they both need to
decide whether this is a good effect so
it's very common and they they would
never force it you know but the very
last clip you know we hear the novice
mister is talking about the young woman
thinking of joining I think she'll do it
but only God knows really it's not in
her hands she's not trying to you know
force anything the woman that I
interviewed who laughed ended up joining
performing community out west I can't
remember which her name is actually Joan
you are oh she's not but there is a
blurb of hers about a book but I
interviewed her and she she became she
about khd she became an authority really
on st. Claire's life has written several
books about st. Claire st. Francis her
name is John Mueller and she teaches
that either Kansas somewhere in Kansas
Nebraska did she did after the six years
hey guys you know a permanent no I mean
really that's very I have not heard of
anyone who has done that during the
process of discernment just really came
to believe the religious board had
actually formed works with migrant
communities and she she still Frances
skin but about the calling to work with
I'm familiar with Paris monastic
tradition and in some of these
traditions deevak actively was Ida
stigmatize no institution see Allah G
very easily led to any way out recognize
Federation very difficult for them
transition back to their life prior
so you describe beautiful interval and
in this talk the challenges that they
face as they came in but exiting is just
as painful if not more for some because
their community and we might or might
not be ready
and it's like and I know personally that
it felt almost like I would rather die
then I totally use this rope sure and I
did I mean I really was curious what
women who had joined this particular
community and left felt and that's not
what I encountered so I really wanted
the book to focus on the community as it
is during that time a number of women
joined and left